alan watts has this quote where he says
we can become so consumed with trying to
improve our lives
that we all together forget to live them
is there a way that people can learn to
let go of this compulsion a little bit
that that's a really good question
um i think my
my second book implicitly answers some
of that
um and explicitly some of it as well but
the implicit part is
there's an increased emphasis on social
ties and so
for me i snap out of the
improvement slash productivity trap to
the degree that i'm able
when i'm playing with my family let's
say
when we're joking when we're sitting
around a meal time together
when when there's peace there and we can
joke and play
and i'm trying as particularly as i'm
trying to regain my health i'm trying to
really rekindle that capacity to play
and enjoy the moment even if i'm not
doing something
productive in and that
that's a very difficult balance to
attain optimally
like any optimal balance is difficult to
attain um
you know it isn't obvious to me how much
of i have no idea the
the multiple sources of my health
troubles i was diagnosed this month with
severe sleep central sleep apnea and so
that was a great relief because i have a
machine now so i breathe properly i was
waking up
uh 25 times an hour apparently
my sleep was so i was getting no
restorative sleep
and so that was one contrib major
contributor and since i've been
breathing at night i've actually been
feeling quite a bit better
unsurprisingly
but i've been scouring my conscience to
determine
if you have an undiagnosed illness
especially if it's severe
it's very likely that you're going to
tear
yourself apart looking for what you did
wrong
to have this arise and
you know i think that
it so i've been considering did i
take on too much responsibility did i
work too much
et cetera et cetera i don't know the
answer to that yet
but what i do know is that since i've
been trying to regain my health
i've been doing a lot of walking and
that's been really good and i'm not
working while i'm walking i'm walking
and
i've been working out more and i've been
playing more and i've been dancing more
and that's all useful and that has to be
balanced with that productivity
because what you're looking for a you're
looking for improvement but you're
looking for sustainable
improvement and so if you push yourself
too hard you
you destroy the sustainability across
time
and and you want that sustainability
there so you can't push yourself any
farther than you're capable of going
in the long run i found for example
because i've written
diligently for a long time daily
and i learned quite early on that
writing more than three hours in a day
was counterproductive
whatever i gained from a four-hour
writing session i'd lose the next day or
two
so but i also think you have to kind of
push yourself past your limits
before you can retract to the optimal
place
and that can't be sort of defined a
priori because each person's
limit is different and i think so i
think what you do when you're young in
your 20s if you're
perhaps if you're operating in an
optimal manner is you push yourself to
your limits and then
pull back and adjust for sustainability
and i helped lots of people do that in
my clinical practice like i work with
lawyers who who are at the pinnacle of
their profession
and the demands on them are incredible
they're working 60 to 80 hours a week
um generally what i did with them was
get them to take more days off they
couldn't work shorter days but they
could plan
four day weekends two months in advance
and they could do that every two months
then inevitably if they did that the
number of billable hours they produced
went up
not down so they maybe doubled their
vacation time and
increased their productivity so it was a
really good deal for them
they got their cake and eat it too they
got to have their cake and eat it too
so do we lean to need to learn to play
in a way
play can be uh we need to remember how
we all know right i mean play is so
deeply embedded in human beings it's
it's one of our primary modes of of of
cognition and
adaptation mammals have a specialized
play circuit that's
that's that's it's biologically
what would you say specialized precisely
for play
and so and it's an interesting circuit
because
a lot of this has been discovered by
people who study animal behavior
especially among rats but
play in rats produces prefrontal lobe
development
and that's the highest that's the part
of the brain that's responsible for
highest order cognition
so rats have to play a lot to mature
properly and they play
socially and social play is social
integration
there's no difference between the
ability to play socially and being
socially integrated
um like a good conversation at
a dinner time is a form of play because
there's wit involved and there's banter
and there's timing and
there's a dance and there's you know
there's the matching of your
physical responses to the physical
response of the other person
it's it's play but play is very easily
inhibited by almost any other
motivational state
and so you can also tell that if you can
get yourself into a playful mood that
that you're in an optimal place
otherwise you wouldn't be able to do it
so it's a good sign that things are
going right thank you very much for
tuning in
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
makes me very happy peace
you